so what uh
i think you talked about an axe of
chopping wood yeah uh
and soul uh from socrates
yeah what is your
soul what is the uh the essence
of sheldon wow that
was like awesome like when god uh
when you when you show up at the end of
this thing he kind of looks at you he's
like oh yeah
yeah i remember you yeah well
you know i to be honest
what i muse about
is to me the when
when people are i told you i have to we
have two kids
uh late 20s early 30s
and over the years
when people when we meet people that
know our kids
and they're like oh your kids are kind
and decent and i'd be like that's what i
would like
to be because i think intelligence is
vastly overrated
you know the unabomber was the smart guy
yeah and i do admire intelligence and i
do venerate
education and i i find that to be
tremendously important but if i had to
pay the ultimate homage to myself
it would be to be known as somebody who
takes himself too seriously to take
myself too seriously
again as corny as it sounds i'd
like to leave the world a tad better
than i found it
or at least do no harm
and um i think you i think you did all
right and that uh
in that regard i love that question alex
that's a good one i think everyone
should be asked that
what is your soul do you have um
maybe just a few lingering questions uh
around it
so you i mean on the on the point of the
soul
you've talked about the the meaning of
life do you have um
on a personal level do you have uh
an answer to the meaning of your life of
something that brought you
meaning uh happiness
some some sense of
sense yeah
no i i mean yes yes and no i mean i
uh a bit you know i'm 66 so i'm in the
kind of not ready to
wrap it up literally or metaphorically
but you look
i look back and
it's just really with a
sense of uh awe and wander gratitude
and is there memories that stand out to
you from childhood from earlier that
like
it's like you know stand out something
you're really proud of
or um just
happy to have been on this earth mainly
that stuff happened yeah that
i mean you know my family um
also a chunk uh we're my folks so my
grandparents are from eastern europe you
know russia austria
um as far as we know some of them never
made it out
i consider myself
very fortunate to have
been a so-called product of the american
dream
you know my grandparents are were
basically
peasants my parents my dad worked two
full-time jobs
um when i was growing up and i would see
him on the weekends i'd be like why are
you working all the time
he'd be like so you won't have to
and he said look the world does not owe
you a living
and so your first responsibility is
to take care of yourself and then your
next responsibility
is to take care of other people
and um i think you did a pretty good job
of that well
i don't know but i i i i so that those
are the things that
i'm proud of
was it's funny you've been if you've
talked about
just yourself as a human being but uh
you've also contributed some really
important ideas
for your ideas and also
kind of integrating and maybe even
popularizing the work of
ernest becker of connecting it uh of
making it legitimate scientifically i
mean
you know as a human of course you want
to be uh
you you want your ripple to be one that
makes the world a better place but also
i think
in the span of time
i think it's of great value you've
contributed in terms of
how we think about the human condition
how we think about
ourselves assuming as uh finite beings
in this world
and i hope also in our technology of
engineering intelligence
i think at least at least for me and i'm
sure there's
a lot of other people uh like me that
your work has been a gift
for so oh well thank you oh no i like
that and
we have described ourselves as giant
interneurons
i'm like we have had no original ideas
and and maybe that's the only thing
that's original about our work is we
don't claim to be original what we claim
to have done is to integrate
to connect these disparate
and superficially unconnected discourses
you know so existentialists they'd be
like
evidence what's that and
yeah there's now a branches psychology
experimental existential psychology that
i think we could
take credit for having encouraged
the formation of and
that in turn has gotten these ideas
in circulation and academic communities
where they may not
have otherwise gotten so i think that's
good
well sheldon is a huge honor i can't
believe
you came down here i've been a fan of
your work
uh i hope we get to talk again huge
honor to talk to you thank you so much
for talking today thanks lex we'll do it
again soon i hope
you